they never get the lessons in little
dabs along the way like you know as kids
we're used to getting these little
lessons along the way
for these zero-sum games often the
lesson just comes fast and hard at the
end it's like oh
this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell and today
we're going to talk about
the problem with xero sub games
so we were chatting dalton and
we've seen a lot of zero-sum games kind
of in our lifetimes it seems like it's
something that
comes and goes pretty pretty often
why don't we start with kind of the
first time you've encountered a zero-sum
game and almost like how you got trapped
by it
yeah so so just to start with
definitions
please um
a zero same game is a game that you play
where the upside that you're getting
comes directly from the other player so
if we're talking about money um a
classic zero-sum game is we make a bet
and so say we bet you know 20 bucks
something will happen
um
and you win the money that you win comes
out of my pocket there's no new money
that's created in the system it's zero
sum so whatever
whatever you gain i lose and it all
equals that to zero okay that's zero sum
a positive sum game
is where something happens and as a
consequence of it
value is created that lasts for a while
and so say that we um
you know
we decided to
do something for fun and we built a
house we're like it'd be fun to build a
house and so
so we do the thing and then when it's
all when it's all said and done
the house exists our labor produced
something that will last you know that
wasn't there before
and we can charge rent for it and maybe
generate some income
yeah exactly so we were entertained in
both scenarios where we you know made a
bet versus built something and in one of
those scenarios it was a we made
something that last and the other one it
was just a zero sum form entertainment
okay
so the most common thing of course i
even had to use it for the example is is
literally gambling
literally gambling is like the textbook
zero-sum game if we play poker
the money that you win came out of
someone else's pocket right if you any
kind of sport
unless you're the house which that's the
actual good business
[Laughter]
and it's it's wild like gambling is fun
maybe not for everyone but
do you do you think
what's
what's your experience with this stuff
i find that gambling
i think it trips one of these things
in everyone's brains that um
makes them feel good but it's probably
bad for them
and i think they're like a lot of things
like that we encounter in the world
right you know let's say sugar is like
that um
nicotine is certainly like that i would
say that you know social media kind of
triggers that feeling of like not
wanting to put it down
um
and gambling is another one of those
things like i would almost say that it
takes advantage of an inherent flaw in
our programming
and i think that flaw has something to
do with
getting disproportionate wins
without the perception of doing
disproportionate amount of work and like
i almost sometimes imagine that there's
got to be some
prehistoric proto-human where like that
was like heaven right like it's like if
you can somehow windfall into
a dead buffalo and you didn't have to
risk your life killing it like bam
that's like huge right
and
i think that unfortunately in today's
age it it it tends to kind of happen in
these ways that aren't as good a lot
gambling
the other part of what you're saying the
darker part of saying is in order for me
to win you have to lose but what's weird
is that there are a lot of things that
kind of resemble gambling but that
people don't call gambling right like
what are some other examples of
quote-unquote gambling out there
well think about it okay so poker is a
game i played a lot um
i'm sure you have two
and in poker
the rules are it's okay to bluff
and you're rewarded like the game is
to manipulate other people around you to
do dumb things
it's not hard to take one extra step to
do that kind of behavior outside of
poker and so there's a whole variety of
both legal and non-legal
confidence games where essentially the
way
you win is to
manipulate people and get them to do
what you want when you want them to do
it
through any means necessary
and
yeah i think
that is rough
and a lot of people do some version of
that i guess we maybe we all do to some
small extent but some people really take
that to the extreme
of um
making their entire living
by you know fooling other people more or
less right well it's crazy because the
you talk about legal versus illegal but
you know back in the day in the u.s i
was reading this biography of morgan
stanley and like
one of the
things that happened in the early night
in the in the early 1900s before a lot
of the financial regulation is that
banks would regularly
kind of sell
really bad paper really bad debt to
um
unassuming normal americans
make a lot of money on the transactions
um i think the the one example i read it
was um some country some country was
speculating they sold a bunch of debt
they couldn't pay it back and a bunch of
americans just lost the money
and the bank forcing the transaction did
fine
the country well they can always print
more money
and
it's interesting because you know in
that time doing that was not illegal
like it wasn't illegal for the bank to
resell something to normal people when
they had knowledge that it was bad paper
but those people didn't
and it's funny how many of the financial
regulations today come from people
in the finance world basically doing
zero-sum games and like harming
normal
americans and harming them so much to
the point where they're like you know
what we should do we should like get a
law passed because this is crazy like
this doesn't scale like this can really
screw a country if um you let people
play these zero some games to the
extreme yeah
and there's some amount of like
lack of empathy or viewing
of intentionally wanting to you know
victimize other people like there's
something there's some dark stuff along
that whole um line of thinking i think
if you feel
that you are smarter than other people
and this is something we encounter
sometimes in our jobs i think if you
feel that you are more intelligent than
others perhaps you can end up on this
slippery slope of moral arguments
that it's okay for you to make a living
off of other people's work because
you you know you use your intelligence
your superior intelligence to get them
to go along with this right you've seen
this a lot
they kind of feel
like that's freedom
like like that's like a free market
system like that's like
that's
okay like they like not even okay like
our system
encourages you to win no matter what
or if you're smart enough to win then
like the means didn't matter
and i think that what's so tricky is
that like it's so obvious the society we
lived in we live in today
was built by people who were playing
positive some games so what it's really
is is like those people created like a
little bit of excess
capital
that the zero-sum game people are like
harvesting
they're kind of like slowly degrading
society and as long as like the positive
some game folks
stay ahead society progresses but in
times where the zero-sum game folks kind
of get too far ahead
i mean we lived through one of those uh
financial crisis uh the last financial
crisis maybe the current one
the the
the second the zero-sum folks get ahead
like the world literally goes to [ __ ]
like it's quite funny how like
the world starts looking really bad when
the zero-sum games take over it's
interesting because this is something
you brought up the idea that like
people are getting rich out there and
i'm missing out
like i think that we've been in the last
four or five years in a zone where like
people are kind of seeing people out
there getting rich with games
that seem too easy
if stocks only go up it is easy it is
yeah you know and you might as well buy
margin because you'll it'll only go up
faster right
i think that
if i can predict the future a little bit
when everything's going up it's easy to
think you're the smart person
when things start going down
you start realizing who the real smart
people are
and tends to be a way way smaller group
than you might think
and turns out that they're taking money
like they're playing the zero-sum game
10x better than you are and they start
taking money from you
and then you start losing faith in the
system
because you ask yourself why did the
system not protect me like i like i
didn't do anything wrong why am i
punished
and it's like like it's like this
negative feedback cycle
that only exists on the zero-sum side
because like our friends who tried and
failed to do positive some games they
almost always learned something or
advanced in some way like they almost
always took something from that game
with them
that made them better off even if they
didn't win
whereas like the folks who are playing
the zero sum games if you don't cash out
that was the only thing you could take
out like that was the only win is like
getting out of the game
they never get the lessons in little
dabs along the way like you know as kids
we're used to getting these little
lessons along the way for these zero-sum
games often the lesson just comes fast
and hard at the end it's like and then
you're you're blown up i mean you do
these office hours with companies
where
it's just game over
like it's like it's good it's good it's
good okay we're dead
there's no warning
um especially when you deal with debt
and leverage which is again related to
this stuff
when you are gambling with money that's
not yours
um
and you're how heavily levered it's
rough
so so let's make let's take this
positive so again like we're seeing all
the
what is right side what's the what's the
advice like how can you make sure what
you're doing
is positive some and like how can you
build enduring value and not
accidentally
you know
what's the move
you know what dalton i i don't think
people are confused whether they're
gambling or building houses
i think that they know whether they're
gambling or building houses
do they
i think they know i think that the thing
they have to resist is the fomo i think
the more
deep question is how do you build houses
when you see a lot of people getting
rich gambling all around you
how do you kind of stay strong
and build a house
when you see people getting rich getting
around you and
you know it's funny because i i had a
friend who was a sports gambler
and i think i learned this lesson
through him
he would always tell me when he won that
weekend
and he'd always bring in like stacks of
cash and he was like i'm way up
and then the weekends he didn't win
he was just silent and i think i always
assumed that like oh like he must not
have gambled that week i don't what do i
know i'm not paying attention
and i think that like
for those people who are looking at the
folks who look like they're winning in
those zero-sum games i think if they
looked a little closer
and they asked themselves like are those
people actually cashing out are those
people actually
doing something sustainable like
are those people drinking the kool-aid
so hard that when the turn comes they
won't be ready for it i think they'll
start realizing that they should feel
less fomo
that's how i feel like how do you feel
about it yeah i think look i think
people can convince themselves of
anything in fact this is definitely
something i've learned over the years is
like no matter how crooked someone is
being they have a story that they
cling to
and they refuse to see it any other way
than that and so
i think you kind of want to look for
external validation that you're building
something of value that's enduring for
people
and
understand be able to articulate that in
a very simple way what that is what is
the leave behind value that
is being created the consequence of my
work and am i winning because someone
else is losing or is like something real
i mean we're seeing this right now with
a bunch of our startups um
a lot of folks okay you know it's hard
out there we can't raise whatever but
our startup's still running like they're
still growing they're still like like
the company is just doing the same thing
and the stuff happening in the external
world is noise yes those people are
doing a real thing that's a positive
sound game yeah
well we're done you know like the people
where immediately the music stopped
that
that's rough like if you're that
sensitive to like market conditions
that um
literally you don't have a company
anymore the minute the markets drop
a lot of the founders to your point are
actually that we work with are actually
solving someone's real problem
and so it turns out that if you're
solving someone's real problem and the
economy goes down it's not like they
still don't have that problem i think
the other thing i think about is
legacy
you know we were joking we know a lot of
rich and unhappy people
and
i think the reason the core
reason why those people are unhappy is
because they're cons
concerned about their legacy
like they realize that making money
and making impact
um aren't one and the same
and i think the older you get and the
more you experience life the more you
realize that like
money's great don't be wrong it's
amazing but like
money can't make you feel good about
yourself
like legacy is what makes you feel good
about yourself i think that like
what's interesting is that as you get
older you start realizing
you know there's this stack of people
who actually progress society and then
there's a stack of people who don't it's
very uncomfortable
and i'd argue most people are on the
stack of people who progress society
like even people you don't consider like
the random person who works in a random
job and like fulfills their their
um duty and like raises kids and teaches
them to do
right and to work hard that person's in
the building society group
um
but there's actually you know a large
number of rich people who are kind of
not in that building society group you
know they made their
money by taking it from others who are
dumber than them
they look back and they're really
concerned and
you kind of can't wash that off yourself
very easily and so
i don't you know
i would just be like hey look like if
you're thinking about this if you feel
like maybe you're caught in this trap
like
think about that legacy think about the
lesson you want to teach your kids
and often say this to founders like hey
when you're dealing with this problem
imagine that you
imagine this problem you brought to me
your group partner
an employee brought to you
what would you tell them to do what
would be the example how do you do the
thing now that would be the example for
your employee or for your child
and then when you think about it that
way you'd be like oh you know you tend
to be like yes i should go after
positive some things
and and if if that's the example if
that's what you'd want your kid to do
you probably should take that advice too
is is kind of how i look at it and
be on the team that's making society
better like in the long run
you'll feel good about that and man like
when you're rich and unhappy like wow
like talk about
talk about negative feedback loops like
you try to spend money to get happiness
and it produces a lot of unhappiness
like
it is impressive
how that
how that happens and drugs and alcohol
and yeti all those things maybe the
other message is if you've got a friend
who's doing the positive sum game
give him a pat on the back
give her a pat on the back like they're
probably taking it on the chin right now
but like man at least they're trying to
play the game the right way yeah i think
what you want to do in every situation
you're in
whether
it is
okay let's extrapolate this whether it's
a startup whether it's a job even if
it's a relationship like we can frame a
lot of things for this is this a
zero-sum situation or positive sun
information like
some situation like in a relationship
imagine
if you make each other better one plus
one equals three like with great
friendships or romantic relationships
you make each other better that's
positive sum
right and so i think this is just like a
helpful framework to look at everything
through
of zero sum versus positive sum and
you know life's short man try to
try to put your energy into
interacting with positive some
situations as much as you can and it'll
pay back in ways you can't even possibly
imagine
and the in the the externalities of it
are much better
like the impact you're gonna have on
other people is gonna be better if you
always choose to play the positive some
games you know
and even if you say screw that be
careful with the zero-sum games because
today you're taking money from a dummy
and tomorrow
you might be the dummy
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right man great chatting dalton
sounds good thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you